on a beaucoup refait une partie du monde
ce soir on n'a pas parlé du vrai
problème de l'humanité
la grippe du poulet j'ai entendu tout le
monde ait terminé son repas
mais moi c'est mon nouveau truc pas ses
nuits sur internet
elles sont spécialisées du tamiflu nous
avons tourné le dos à tout départ nous
avons les matches mais pas n'importe
lesquels ceux qui colle et où j'ai mon
petit pédiluve on a préparé les pattes
je vous préviens c'est les débuts
d'exemple maire d'ax les gens n'ont pas
parlé de la peste aviaire
ça s'appelle comme ça le sens le type le
titre médical c'est peste aviaire s'est
pas grippe a vient c'est peste aviaire
moi ça fait déjà un an et demi que je
soul tout le monde
oui j'ai j'ai maintenant mais si jamie
endroit où je vais sur internet j'ai mes
infos je corresponds avec des médecins
qui pensent que tu mets ça parce que moi
et je me suis permis comme c'est par
internet pour avoir des vrais documents
sérieuse mais docteur j'vais dr demande
en eau et on voit des trucs c'est plus
sérieux et moi je pense que on n'est pas
à l'abri d'une pandémie colossal je ne
veux pas paniquer les populations
d'aucune la france a commenté 600
millions de masques paraissait moins
nous sommes à 15 millions de boîtes de
médicaments stoxx 600 millions et 1 2
million de masques ils sont énormes
indigents profiteurs je sais de source
sûre 600 millions de masses et c'est le
nombre de masques c'est pas pour les
civils en fait c'est le nombre de mâts
comme les masques sont à renouveler
toutes les douze heures toutes les six
heures c'est le nombre minimum de masse
pour protéger les personnels médicaux
qui sont entreprises qui sont liées au
ps et l'ump qui fabrique les comptes
la question n'est pas de savoir est-ce
qu'on va le vivre c'est quand le
couvre-feu ils ont déjà préparé tout
comment l'armée va rentrer pour pâques
et des pillards comment ils vont
protéger les femmes il fut les 15
millions de boîtes à 40 millions qui
sont qu'ils sont en compte qui sont
commandés dont elles sont commandées
le tamiflu est dans les temps les
pharmacies militaires dans les espèces
de 200 les gens qu'elles sont prêtes à
être diffusée ce matin
non nous avons dîné arthur et moi avec
un an avec un ministre on ne s'y trompe
avions été très gai pendant tout le
dîner et au moment où on a commencé à
parler de la paix stagiaire d'un seul
coup ils étaient ils avaient l'air
tragique fait flipper un homme il ya de
quoi je me rends compte y a un truc on
va pas dire
ça fait maintenant un mois ça fait un
mois que j'exige de mon épouse qu'elle
commande des pâtes et se moquent de moi
le comment de quoi agiter pas de quoi
tenir un mois de l'huile des pâtes du
riz barrages et elle elle se marre est
et elle se marre et je les dix
ascensions être sans qu'ils savent des
build est hypocondriaque le dos je
rentre à la maison je sors comme ça
qu'on était chez nous quand logique
tient plan que ça ils sont des boîtes de
tamiflu
moi j tamiflu pour toute ma famille
ouais ouais je n'ai pas il faut pas que
la grippe arrive tout de suite tant à la
diète attendre ouais je vous dis que
sega prend le halo on peut le changer
suis dit oui je louche on a loupé le
champ comment ça va être le chant et
dans les années sont aussi qu'on va tous
avoir la grippe aviaire paul chan la
hausse et arthur qui l'a dit d'accord ok
2 s'écoule en chanteur passe d'annie un
chat
il arrive avec la femme on va très bien
ok j'étais dans un ascenseur charles de
gaulle jeu l'ascenseur s'ouvre je rentre
et il ya sept chinois qui rentre dans
l'ascenseur comme ça le fait non c'est
pas eu tellement de ya juste un chinois
un mètre de moi qui fais
comme ça je me fais des ccp de paniquer
parce qu'ils les chinois le pauvre mais
je respire plus quand même moi j'ai un
copain qui est qui et dans la quête
trader et qui m'expliquait que quand
l'or se met à monter très très vite
c'est qu'un coup tordu qui se prépare
est la norme et la explose un coup tordu
du genre c'est à dire que quand quand on
commence à faire des réserves d'or quand
les gouvernements commencent à augmenter
leurs réserves et n'en sait que jaguar e
qui serait pas je vous ai bien [ __ ] le
moral à ce soir pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous il
m'était impossible ou